bonjour c'est cyprien
ouais j'ai réussi hier soir pendant mon
cours privés de karim sur gazon
j'essayais de penser la chose la plus
absurde de la planète terre et j'ai
trouvé ce que c'est ces jeux vidéo si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi pensez
juste une seule chose quel est le jeu le
plus vendu de tous les temps
c'est le jeu le plus bizarre du monde ok
les matches j'ai un concept là alors le
jeu ça va être un plombier avec une
moustache qui doit sauver une française
quand il mange et champignons il grandit
il peut sauter sur des tortues il peut
monter sur le dos de d'un dinosaure ce
sera le jeu le plus vendu de tous les
temps
ah oui et puis comme on in entreprises
japonaises on va lui donner un nom
italien qui me suis d'ailleurs il ya un
truc absolument irréaliste dans les jeux
vidéo c'est la jauge de vie
non ça n'existe pas un t'as pas une
jauge de vie comme ça à côté de ta
gueule mais hassa dans presque tous les
jeux vidéo tu peux te prendre une balle
dans l'épaule comme ça une balle dans la
tête une balle dans le ventre
ap hm étaient toujours vivants puisque
il te reste de la vie a rompu ce temps
la cheville et la tumeur non non tu te
prends une balle tu meurs comme une
merde c'est comme ça c'est ça c'est la
réalité
bon ça aix en jauge de vie des jeux
vidéo ce sera un petit peu chiant
nouvelle partie aux jeux terminés
j'ai payé ce jeu 70 euros ensuite en
terme d' absurdité tu as des genres de
jeux qui sont plus ou moins servir comme
par exemple les jeux de rôle les rpg je
crois que sony seront plutôt pas mal
d'armes de n'importe quoi de combat au
tour par tour par exemple c'est comme
cette idée attaque alors ah non non non
non c'est à ton tour et après donc tu me
pète la gueule moi je vais bien vivre
c'est bien ça ok autre truc complètement
débiles dans les rpg souvent pour
avancer dans l'histoire tu dois les de
village en village tu vois parler à des
gens rentrés dans leur maison d'où tu
rentres dans les maisons des gens comme
ça bonjour je regarde juste un jeu un
petit moment les jeux de baston aussi
ils sont pas mal dans le genre il ya un
truc qui ne choque absolument personne
tu peux faire combattre riou contre rio
tout va bien tu dis un truc le visage de
la bnda même classe par hasard en cours
de latin en cours de poterie en cours de
carling sur gazon je sais ce que vous
vous dites nous dit euh ouais c'est prix
de la critique
elle propose rien et c'est ok d'accord
ok je vais faire une proposition pour
améliorer les jeux vidéos on arrête de
laisser le choix du nom des personnages
aux joueurs peut-être de qu utilisent
combo griffe ça sert à rien à part être
méchant envers les personnages du jeu
vidéo c'est déjà pas mal à vous faites
si vous rejoignez ma page facebook
vous offre de l'amour à vous faites
numéro 2 parce que je numéro tenait au
fait c'est pour mieux me retrouver
j'ai un nouveau blog cyprien point fr
parce que c'est mon prénom
si j'avais pris jean-charles point fr
non ça aurait pas de sens
[Musique]